i'm really in rarefied here of like  deep obsession with my process and  enjoyment and lack of anxiety from it  and lack of burnout from it i think i  hit my crescendo i think i'm more of an  artist  i don't think people realize that  business women and men are actually  there's a certain version of us that are  artists that generally like this  more than anything  like like we like singing like beyonce  is a workaholic  yeah you know like kobe was a workaholic  obsession over their craft their art  their expressions yeah so for me like  like we demonize it in in  entrepreneurship and corporate life but  we don't in art  we put artists we put oh he's in the  studio all the time wow you know  painting all the time wow  cooking and traveling the world to buy  food wow business oh he's going to burn  out he's going to suicidal